le peintre soulage de notoriété mondiale
se voit consacré dans son pays au musée
d'art moderne de paris l'exposition est
intitulée noir lumière titre paradoxal
mais il est vrai que le noir de soulages
ne ressemble à aucun autre
georges bigot pascal pire dans le titre
tout est dit pour soulage aujourd'hui le
noir n'est pas une couleur mais un
miroir de pigments qui ne réfléchit pas
seulement mais capte la lumière dans ces
rainures joue avec elle s'identifie à
elle et à certains endroits la refuse on
est prié de ne pas chercher à comprendre
mais de regarder de ressentir rien n'est
moins cérébral qu'un tableau soulages le
peintre ne raconte rien et n'accorde
aucun sens au tableau l'émotion la
méditation guide sa main et son
prolongement naturel l'outil un outil
rudimentaire d'artisans qu'il préfère au
pinceau de marbre des artistes
traditionnels j'ai plaisir à me trouver
dans la rue en train de faire dans le
jeu une sûreté demain beaucoup plus
grande que si j'étais sur une bricole le
hall a tendance à a dévié je trouve
qu'il ya un côté plus franc direct dans
ce que je fais de cette manière là et
quand je suis seul à emma toile schultz
en libre et là peuvent intervenir des
choses profondes secrète
ces choses secrètes les origines de son
art viennent de loin de son enfance
aveyronnaise soit le monde impressionné
par les menhirs du musée de rodez dont
les griffures les rainures qui ont
quatre mille ans rappelle la manière de
soulage
c'est peut-être à cause de l'égo des
émotions j'ai eu devant ces objets que
j'ai été amené à guetter pendant que je
peignais des moments d'origine
au delà de l'exposition parisienne
on peut aller admirer à conques
l'abbatiale dont soulage a réalisé les
vitraux mariant ses propres rythmes au
rythme de l'architecturé romane tous
travaillent ici a duré huit ans mais
pour moi ça n'a pas été une vraie
rupture parce que cette est en parfaite
continuité avec ce que je faisais avant
est ce que je fais maintenant la lumière
toujours la lumière le noir lui va si
bien